In case you missed it, Marines in One Piece
have bounties now.
That’s thanks to Mihawk’s & Crocodile’s
newly formed Cross guild organization, that
pulled the ultimate uno reverse card and is
now putting money on the head’s of marines.
So let’s try and predict what the bounty
of the top level marines will be.
Starting with Luffy’s grandfather, vice
admiral Monkey D. Garp, known as the hero
of the marines.
How much Garp is one of the oldest still active
Marines.
However, no one would make the mistake to
underestimate this man, even now.
As father of the world’s most wanted criminal
Monkey D. Dragon and grandfather of the current
Yonko and future pirate king Monkey D. Luffy,
it’s no big surprise that Garp used to be
one of the strongest marines in history.
He and fleet admiral Sengoku were the faces
of the Marine forces during the legendary
era of the likes of Gol D. Roger, Whitebeard
and Rocks D. Xebec.
The only reason that Garp stayed only at vice
admiral level was because he repeatedly refused
a promotion to either admiral or fleet admiral.
That’s because in these positions you are
at the direct disposal of the Celestial Dragons,
the corrupt ruling class of One Piece, that
Garp himself despises.
During his prime Garp regularly clashed with
the strongest pirates in One Piece history,
and was respected by all of them.
Not only did he train Luffy as a kid, but
also the current generation of elite marine
fighters, such as Aokiji.
And even though Garp is serving in more of
an advisory position at this point, we can
assume, that he is still one of the most powerful
marines in existence.
After all, during the war at Marineford, Sengoku
had to stop him from attacking Akainu, seemingly
genuinely worried that Garp would kill the
strongest admiral after he killed ace.
So what’s his bounty going to be?
Now, we haven’t actually seen any of the
marines bounties officially yet, so there
is nothing we can anchor our estimate to.
It seems that instead of a number the bounty
amounts are indicated by symbols.
The once we’ve seen so far are two stars
three stars and a crown.
I would assume that each symbol corresponds
to either a certain marine rank or a certain
amount of money.
We also have no idea how much money Crocodile
and Mihawk actually have to finance these
marine bounties.
It could be a lot less than regular pirate
bounties, given the world governments massive
financial resources.
However we do know that Crossguild has a lot
of backing from the criminal underworld in
One Piece, so I think for the sake of this
video, let’s just assume that Buggy, Mihawk
and Crocodile have a lot of free cashflow
allocated to this project.
And so let’s also assume that Marine bounties
and Pirate bounties are on the exact same
level.
That makes them a lot easier to deduce and
compare.
For Garp, that means that as a legend of the
marines who could fight with the likes of
Roger, Whitebeard and Rocks, he would absolutely
be in the top tier of Marine bounties.
So if we compare him to the bounties of these
legends, if I was Crocodile, I think it would
be fair to give Garp a 3 Billion berry bounty,
the same as his grandson Luffy.
That reflects his power and former Glory,
but also factors in that he has grown old
and only receives his bounty now at 78 years
old.
In terms of the cross guild poster, that could
be 3 crowns for instance.
In contrast to a legend like Garp, what would
be the bounty of someone like Luffy’s former
Marine rival smoker?
The reason I find him a very interesting example
here, is because smoker went from a character
far more powerful than Luffy, to the point
where none of the straw hats could do anything
against him, to a marine we all would see
as relatively weak, especially after he got
completely humiliated by Doflamingo on Punk
Hazard.
At some point, Luffy and in fact all of the
straw hats passed him in power.
I would argue that this happened during the
timeskip, Luffy Zoro and Sanji learned Haki
and thus Smokers big advantage, his Logia
fruit, become irrelevant.
So even though Smoker is now a vice-admiral
like Garp, I would give him a bounty of 300
Million Berries, same as Luffy after defeating
Crocodile and a bit less than current Nami,
which I think is pretty much the best he could
hope for.
Let’s compare that to the three current
admirals.
Kizaru, Fujitora and Ryokugyuu are the top
3 strongest fighters in the Marines next to
Akainu right now.
We actually don’t know if the admirals could
actually match a Yonko 1vs1, but they are
pretty much the Marine equivalent to the emperors.
Therefore i think they should have decently
high bounties, definitely in the billion berry
range.
From Crocodiles perspective, the lowest bounty
should go to Greenbull.
Not only was he not exactly convincing with
his appearance in Wano, despite his incredible
awesome devil fruit, but Crocodile’s desert
logia powers are pretty much Greenbull’s
weakness.
So overall, he is probably the admiral Cross
Guild needs to be the least worried about.
Since he is an active admiral I would give
him a higher bounty than Garp, but a lower
one than Blackbeard, so 3.5 Billion berries
seems like a good number.
Kizaru is a different beast.
Despite his apparently lazy attitude, he is
always eager to face the strongest opponents
possible on his own.
And we have already seen multiple times how
devastating and effective he can be.
3.8 billion berries sounds like a good fit
for him.
And now you may be surprised that Fujitora
gets the highest bounty out of all 3 of the
admirals, but remember that he was the one
who got rid of the warloard system in the
first place and immediately started a hunt
for Crocodile Mihawk and co.
For sure he will be the most focused on this
new group formed by former warloards and thus
poses the biggest threat for Cross Guild.
If you take down Fujitora, you get 4 Billion
berries.
Alternatively if you subscribe to the channel,
you get fresh, high quality one piece content
ever single week.
Moving on to the only character that has had
an even more impressive glow up than Luffy
throughout one piece.
The very first friend he makes in the story:
Koby.
Now Koby might not seem like a major threat
at first glance, but that’s because you
know him as a friend of Luffy.
Actually more fanboy than friend.
But from an outside perspective, Koby grew
from a tiny 12 year old looking guy, into
a full grown man in just two years.
He went from sweeping decks to a full blown
marine captain in record time.
He has been personally trained by Garp, who
as you know trained the likes of Aokiji, he
has mastered Haki, the techniques of the six
powers and is part of the secret marine organization
sword.
Crocodile, Mihawk and Buggy saw Koby standing
up to Akainu during the marineford war and
saw Shanks protecting him.
And they might well know that he is aiming
to become an admiral himself.
So I think it’s more than reasonable to
give Koby the Hero, a bounty of at least 500
Million berries for his fast rise through
the ranks.
His buddy helmeppo meanwhile I would give
250 million maybe, a bit less than smoker.
Next we have one of the most mysterious characters
in the series: Kong.
In case you don’t know who that is, it’s
because there is barely anything we know about
this character, even though he is technically
the most important marine in One Piece.
During Garp’s and Sengoku’s era, he was
the previous Fleet admiral, the highest rank
within the marines, until he got promoted.
To what you ask?
Well, his current position is that of World
Government Commander in chief.
In other words, the only people ranking higher
than Kong in the world are the five elders
and Imu themselves.
Kong not only has full control over the entire
Marine system, but also commands the government
secret agencies, Enies Lobby and Impel Down,
and even the 7 warlords of the sea, when they
were still a thing.
Sengoku had to come to his office to offer
his resignation as fleet admiral.
And it was technically also Kong who officially
declared Akainu the new fleet admiral.
While Sengoku and Garp lead the current generation
of top marines, Kong led the generation of
Sengoku and Garp.
So we can only assume how powerful he must
be.
Plus look at this man’s forearms and his
face scar.
And he has a monkey theme, just like Luffy.
So this dude knows how to fight.
Similar to Garp and Sengoku, he is quite old,
but due to his strength and especially his
political power, taking him out would truly
throw the entire world government into complete
chaos.
So, I personally think that despite the little
we know about him, Kong deserves the second
highest marine bounty of 4.5 billion berries.
Because the highest Marine bounty will without
any doubt go to the scariest and as far as
we know currently strongest Marine in One
Piece.
Fleet admiral Sakazuki, formerly known as
Admiral Akainu.
Akainu has been built up by Oda to be one
of the main villains of the story.
He is the reason for both Luffy’s and Robin’s
deepest and darkest moment.
He is the marine that goes hard against any
pirate, no matter the circumstance and as
we know, he does have the power to back it
up.
As the current fleet admiral, he is the head
of the marine forces, and even though Kong
is above him in rank, the story suggests that
there is no Marine that is more powerful than
him at the moment.
As the biggest threat to Cross Guild and pirates
in general, Akainu deserves the highest bounty
out of all marines.
I’m incredibly curious to find out how the
cross guild bounty system actually works and
how much each marine will be worth.
But in the context of this video, I think
Akainu deserves a 4.8 billion berry bounty.
With that he would also make it into the top
5 of the highest pirate bounties.
If you want to know who is above him and all
remaining 1 billion plus bounties, you can
watch that video right here.